on va parler gaz hilarant à présent mais
pour la bonne cause covid 19 guerre en
Ukraine et maintenant inflation de plus
en plus de Français souffrent de
dépression et parmi eux certains
patients résistants aux antidépresseurs
classiques un chercheur tourangeau vient
de publier une étude prometteuse sur les
bénéfices d'un traitement à base de
protoxyde d'azote le fameux gazilant
pour ces cas difficiles il est avec nous
ce soir bonsoir professeur Thomas les
Smith donc professeur de psychiatrie
chercheur dans l'unité Inserm imagerie
et cerveau de l'Université de Tours une
étude publiée dans la revue moléculaire
d'abord comment vous est venu l'idée du
gazilarant pour traiter ses patients
soulager la dépression résistante est-ce
que c'est une intuition où ça vient de
travaux de plus anciens oui c'est ça on
avait en fait des données plutôt
préliminaires en fait des études
américaines qui nous montrait qu'il y
avait probablement un effet
antidépresseur avec des gaz à base de en
effet de protoxyde d'azote chez les
patients avec une dépression résistante
particulièrement sévère et donc on a
voulu savoir dans notre équipe ce qui se
passait en réalité dans le cerveau de
ses patients et des pressions sévères et
c'est pour ça qu'on a mené cette étude
en effet alors vous avez mené une étude
sur une trentaine de patients c'est bien
cela que se passe-t-il justement dans le
cerveau quand c'est patients prennent du
protoxyde d'azote ce gaz là rend alors
on a observé un effet tout à fait
surprenant en fait puisque on a observé
chez les patients qui répondaient c'est
à peu près 50% des sujets qui ont été
soumis à ce à ce à ce produit et bien
qu'il y avait des modifications dans la
façon dont se connecter le cerveau dans
les différentes parties du sabre en fait
et ça ça nous conforte dans l'idée qu'il
y a probablement un effet
antidépresseur qui a une base
mécanistique dans le cerveau avec un
effet tout à fait évident qu'on a pu
observer dans ces connexions on la voit
cette petite partie on va peut-être le
revoir cette petite partie du cerveau
que se passe-t-il quelle est la zone
touchée par ce traitement oui alors ça
s'appelle le cortex singulaire antérieur
donc c'est une zone un peu un peu
technique mais qu'une partie importante
dans la dans la régulation émotionnelle
dans la dépression c'est bien on sait
que une zone impliquée dans la réponse
thérapeutique et finalement on sait
qu'en réduisant
l'hyperactivation de cette zone et bien
on réduit aussi les symptômes négatifs
de la dépression comme les ruminations
les idées noires parfois des suicidaires
dont on sait que c'est parfois
dramatique évidemment je sais pas alors
ça peut être très surprenant quand on
parle de gazilarant de protoxyde d'azote
en fait c'est un produit qui est très
ancien et c'est connu oui c'est ça on
l'utilise depuis des dizaines d'années
en fait dans la dans en médecine en
général dans les indications plutôt de
la douleur des soins douloureux chez les
enfants chez les femmes enceintes aussi
qui qui avant une opération exactement
avant une opération avant un soin comme
une voilà une des futurs ce genre de
choses et en effet
ça fait depuis finalement assez
longtemps qu'on connaît l'effet
antalgique en revanche les fait
antidépresseurs et de découvert toute
récente on veut en savoir davantage et
donc on voulait mener cette étude qui a
été tout à fait surprenante pour nous et
reprise par de nombreux autres collègues
pendant longtemps la psychiatrie a été
le parent pauvre vraiment de la
recherche avec peu de nouveaux
médicaments mis sur le marché c'est en
train de changer avec la redécouverte de
ce qu'on peut appeler certaines drogues
en tout cas qui étaient utilisées comme
tel oui c'est ça alors c'est vrai que
les nouvelles générations
d'antidépresseurs qui ont l'avantage et
on l'espère en tout cas d'avoir un effet
rapide par rapport aux antidépresseurs
conventionnelle qui mettent un certain
temps à voir avant d'avoir un effet
clinique pas de temps et c'est vrai que
parmi ces nouvelles drogues ces
nouvelles ces nouvelles ça ne vous
antidépresseurs et bien figure les
psychédéliques qui ne sont pas encore
arrivés en France on attend d'avoir des
résultats plus robustes mais en effet
certains produits à base de de
psilocybine ou de produits équivalents
ou de kétamine en effet sont des
produits qui commencent à arriver en
France certains sont en utilisation de
routine actuellement les sketamines qui
est déjà utilisé
qui a eu une autorisation de mission de
marché il y a il y a quelques mois
maintenant et qui est utilisé en effet
ici au CHU dans d'autres centres
spécialisés pour la dépression
résistante chez certains patients assez
sévères en effet quand on verra-t-on le
protoxyde d'azote utilisé dans les dans
les hôpitaux alors voilà d'abord
peut-être préciser qu'en effet c'est un
gaz médical à base évidemment ce n'est
pas le protoxyde d'azote de l'oxygène
également exactement c'est un mélange à
50% d'oxygène 50% de protoxyde d'azote
et en effet on doit confirmer son
efficacité son efficacité clinique nous
on a en effet montré qu'il y avait un
effet mécanique dans le cerveau mais il
reste à le démontrer dans des études
plus robustes on espère ces études
d'ailleurs sont en cours pour pour en
partie au CHU en particulier chez les
personnes de 2,60 ans et plus et on
espère finalement avoir des résultats
d'ici deux ou trois ans et peut-être une
utilisation d'ici 4 ou 5 ans en soins
courants je l'espère en tout cas merci
beaucoup Thomas desmith c'est
encourageant donc cette étude pour tous
les patients qui souffrent de dépression
résistance vous êtes donc psychiatrie
chercheur à l'université tout merci
beaucoup d'être venu ce soir sur notre
plateau merci